Hey Thoughty2 here.
The founder of match.com, Gary Kremen, lost
his girlfriend to a man she met on match.com.
Welcome to RIF.
1.
The sun's core is so hot that a piece of it
the size of a pinhead would give off enough
heat to kill a person 160 kilometres away.
2.
Women buy 80% of everything that is for sale.
Which means that 8 out of every 10 purchases
made around the world in a single day are
made my women.
3.
Ants can survive in a microwave because they
are small enough to dodge the rays.
4.
The Great Pyramids used to be as white as
snow because they were encased in a bright
limestone that has worn off over the years.
5.
Jellyfish evaporate in the sun, because they're
98% water.
6.
In the course of an average lifetime you will,
whilst sleeping, eat 70 assorted insects and
10 spiders.
7.
A person can live without food for about a
month, but only about a week without water.
If the amount of water in your body is reduced
by just 1%, you'll feel thirsty.
If it's reduced by 10%, you'll die.
8.
Hot water is heavier than cold water, because
it contains more energy.
9.
Elephants can die from a broken heart.
They are highly emotional animals and will
mourn the loss of loved ones, often going
into withdrawal, which sometimes causes death.
10.
There is a term for the opposite of "ambidextrous".
It's "ambisinister", and it means you're equally
crap with both hands.